[Music]
what's going on guys my name is David
Thomas welcome back to the channel today
we're talking about the importance of
designing at your product packaging it's
no longer just about the product itself
unboxing experience has become one of
the most important things about selling
your product in 2019 if you're around my
age you probably remember back in the
day when you used to purchase a brand
new toy or a CD or anything along the
lines from shops it used to come in just
some plain packaging nothing special
most the time you'd come in over
standard cardboard brown box with a
little bit of packaging and it may be a
little bit of a logo but it wasn't
anything special the money and time from
these companies was really spent on
developing the products it wasn't until
social media became such a big deal in
our lives and companies like Apple came
along and caused the paradigm shift that
we really started focusing on our
product packaging just as much as we
focused on the product itself nowadays
as a company or a brand it's almost just
as important to sell product to somebody
as it is to have somebody take that
photo and post on Instagram later now
isn't just me that thinks product
packaging is very important to your
company into your brand there are
YouTube content creators out there like
unbox therapy that are creating a living
of just unboxing different products and
showing you what's inside this box that
channel line has 14 million subscribers
people like you and me who are really
interested in unboxing this product and
just seeing how it comes what's inside
the box and what other things are inside
the box beside the product itself
sometimes a little added booklet or a
little tool or something special in the
Box can convince somebody to buy that
product over another and that's the
reason companies like my own spend
thousands and thousands of dollars and
hundreds of hours developing and
researching different types of boxes and
unpackaging experiences when a new
product arrives at a customer's door
it's very important to a brand and to a
company and that customer enjoys the
unboxing experience it's smooth it's
perfect and it's clean it makes them
really enjoy the product a little bit
more and it makes them feel like they've
been thought about the added benefit in
2019 of creating a unique product with a
unique
boxing experience is the fact that your
customers may potentially post this
product online social media nowadays is
a number one key selling point to sell
anything so when a customer posts a
picture of their brand new watch for
example they're going to show their
friends potentially 100 500 500 thousand
people that you've never had access to
before one photo like this and one share
like this can be worked more than
spending tens of thousands of dollars
online on Facebook marketing and
Instagram marketing because these people
are very interested in their friends and
their family and what they're doing and
what they're spending their money on now
if you're new to this channel and have
no idea about my past experience in
business one of the companies I've
created in the past is called wild
watches there's a link in the
description if you want to check it out
and see what I do for a living
so far there's been two collections
launched and two completely different
unboxing experiences the first
collection featured a unique white box
that created an unboxing experience
different to anything on the market at
the time launched the intention of this
unboxing experience was to create
something different and unique something
a customer would remember and really
enjoy unboxing again and again so being
the first collection that I ever
launched I wanted this box to be
something special and I wanted the
customer to take a little bit of time to
enjoy all the details and the processes
behind creating something like a watch a
single leaflet at the bottom depicted
how a customer could easily set up their
watching four simple steps it really
created a unique experience for them and
it wasn't just grab the watch out of the
box put her on and forget about it it's
just another watch this unboxing
experience encourage the customer to put
together to watch and understand that
all the straps and all the combinations
were completely interchangeable if this
was by any chance missed on the website
or it wasn't conveyed properly the
customer really understood straight away
when they unboxed his products the
second collection was called the
midnight collection and obviously the
midnight collection had to come in a
black box so the reasoning behind this
packaging here was the fact that the
second collection was really about
creating a gift to the customer
themselves they had provided myself and
others the opportunity to continue a
dream that was never before possible
unlike the original collection the
midnight collection did come assembled
now the reason behind this was to really
encourage the customers
to understand more so about the brand
and the watch itself so inside the
packaging a little unique booklet was
created just showing pictographic images
of how the watch could be assembled how
it could be adjusted and how anything
could be changed on the timepiece itself
now having a unique box and a unique
product unpackage comes with its pros
and cons being a small company that
doesn't produce millions and millions of
products every single week there are
some drawbacks to creating a unique box
that takes time and effort by the
company to produce so for example the
midnight collection box which is a
smooth transitional 2-piece unit costs
about $10 to make for most people
something like this would be just thrown
into the bin and completely forgotten
about but others it would have been the
key difference between purchasing one of
our watches and somebody else's a little
piece of advice that I've learned over
the years is if you're creating a unique
unboxing experience make sure you set
some time aside to create and develop
this box itself the product can take six
to twelve months to create but the box
itself can again take something like
three to six months to create on top of
that as you begin developing your
product and things change parts change
it becomes bigger and smaller the boxes
have to adjust in size and shape to suit
as well so make sure you request the
sample of every single box that you
create before you go to for production
if you're thinking about creating your
very own product packaging and your very
own unique product there's multiple ways
to think about it products packaging
itself if you're creating a sleek
stylish product that's very thin and
narrow maybe consider the box to be as
still as possible otherwise if you're
creating something that's extravagant
and very expensive take a look at
something like the Samsung Galaxy fold
the box comes in a box in a box in a box
there's more and more on packaging and
different experiences inside the one
unit considering the number of products
that Samsung has pushed out for this
product the boxes probably didn't cost
them that much but they still would have
been upwards of $50 just in the single
unboxing experience however it does
create a very luxurious feel and if
that's a product that you're selling
upwards of $2000 well maybe it's
something you can sit up because the
customer isn't going to be very happy if
the $2000 product comes in a very basic
cardboard box and it feels like they're
being chipped out and that's all I have
for you guys today on unboxing and the
unbox
experience if there's anything you'd
like to know more about today's topic
make sure you drop a comment down below
otherwise smash that subscribe button
20-19 style I'll see you next Monday